à paris ce mercredi se tenait une
réunion de conseillers politiques de la
russie de l'ukraine de l'allemagne et de
la france toujours pour trouver une
issue diplomatique à ce conflit larvé le
conseiller rue s'est exprimée à
l'instant à l'issue de cette journée de
discussions il annonce à qu'une nouvelle
réunion des conseillers aura lieu dans
deux semaines à berlin ont rejoint
moscou notre correspondant julian
colline pour savoir est ce qu'il faut
retenir de ce rendez vous aujourd'hui
est ce que julian ces rendez vous au
format 10 de normandie reste important
pour la diplomatie russe
oui ça reste sans doute important il
faut d'abord rappeler que cette réunion
d'aujourd'hui est la première depuis
très longtemps il n'y avait plus eu de
réunion au fort mal en bandit donc à 4
depuis plus d'un an est donc bien sûr la
russie déjà le kremlin et les médias
russes par exemple salue toujours quand
la russie est présente à la table des
négociations avec des pays occidentaux
c'est toujours bien vu s ça permet de
donner aussi de l'importance au
processus diplomatique russe mais plus
important pour la russie que les faits
les rencontres au format normandie elle
même c'est ce qu'il ya derrière en fait
c'est le but de ces rencontres qui est
extrêmement important pour la russie et
c'est donc en réalité les accords de
minsk qui pour rappel donc le les
réunions format normandie sont censés
être négocié pour réussir à trouver une
implémentation de ces accords de
ministres qui ont été décidés déjà et
qui ont été en tout cas dans les
ébauches avait été créée il ya déjà plus
de sept ans à la suite d'une action d'un
crime et les premiers confidents en
ukraine et en fait qu'ils n'ont jamais
été mis en place ces accords sont
totalement gelée au point mort depuis
depuis cette époque là et donc la russie
sans doute beaucoup d'experts ici à
moscou disait même que le but de cacher
en fait de toutes ces manoeuvres russe
depuis quelques semaines
près de la frontière ukrainienne c'est
justement de mettre la pression sur kiev
pour accepter enfin est signé ces
accords de minsk qui sont pour rappel
également de l'avis de tous même mais
moscou les les gens honnêtes le
reconnaissent qu'ils sont très
défavorables en fait à kiev et qu'ils
sont plutôt favorables à la russie et
aux républiques séparatistes du dombass
parce que pour rappel ces accords de
minsk en fait
accorderait des statuts particuliers est
quasiment une fédération d'ukraine avec
des accords avec des statuts très
particulier et très indépendant pour ces
républiques de l'est de l'ukraine est
donc bien sûr c'est totalement
inacceptable en l'état par kiev et c'est
pour cela que les deux parties sont
encore très loin d'un accord et donc ce
n'est que la première rencontre
aujourd'hui encore une fois on est sans
doute très très loin d'un rapprochement
rapide des positions à voir dimitri
kozak a déclaré ce soir qu'il était prêt
avec la russie était prête à peut-être
mettre la pression un peu plus sur les
séparatistes pro russes pour peut-être
un peu plus est conscient également donc
à voir si ce processus va continuer dans
ces négociations autour de l'ukraine il
y avait aussi aujourd'hui la réponse
américaine aux demandes rue c'est ce
qu'on sait si la russie pourrait s'en
satisfaire
c'est très difficile à dire parce que
encore une fois personne ne peut
réellement se mettre dans l'esprit de
vladimir poutine et des ses proches
conseillers au kremlin même les experts
ici à moscou reconnaisse que c'est
difficile à prévoir ce que ce que ce que
vaut réellement mettre en place les
armées russe et la lumière poutine
lui-même ce qui est sûr c'est que la
l'otan aujourd'hui également anthony
blinken ont répondu de manière assez
ferme dans la presse en tout cas les
documents semblent assez ferme c'est une
fin de non recevoir pour la russie il
n'y aura pas comme elle le souhaitait
comme elle exigeait de d'accord écrit
sur une extension de l'otan vers loin
vers l'est
les occidentaux rappelle que bien la
russie n'a pas le droit à demander en
fait un droit de veto sur qui adhère ou
pas à l'otan et que c'est le droit
souverain des pays à faire ce qu'ils
veulent donc concernant l'ukraine bien
sûr et donc la russie à voir comment ils
vont réagir à cette réponse relativement
ferme encore une fois américaine qui
était prévisible à moscou personne ne
s'attendait bien sûr à ce que voilà le
temps où le washington acceptent ses
exigences très élevées de la russie mène
peut-être que voilà cette réponse écrite
a été donnée ça y est les russes le
réclamer à cor et à cri est depuis
longtemps et désormais ça peut ouvrir
peut-être une nouvelle séquence
diplomatique avec blinken qui doivent
bientôt à nouveau appelé sergueï lavrov
peut-être que les deux ministres des
affaires étrangères vont se rencontrer à
nouveau très prochainement pour
peut-être trouver des compromis même si
pour l'instant ça reste assez difficile
et assez loin encore une fois quelques
sujets existe tout de même pour des
rapprochements peut-être notamment lé
déploiement de missiles de d'armes
balistiques ou encore les traité de non
prolifération nucléaire c'est peut-être
des dames ou qui seront on peut trouver
un accord mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
sur le sujet de l'otan vraiment une
ligne rouge pour la russie c'est
difficile de voir pour l'instant un
quelconque dégel entre les deux
positions